au Sénat un mot sur cette dernière étape
a priori dans l'examen de la réforme et
le Sénat qui adopte cette conclusion de
la commission disparitaire pardon
d'abord le Sénat adopté cette réforme
qui est importante cette réforme elle
est là pour sauver le régime de retraite
par répartition s'il explose sous le
poids des déficits ce serait les plus
fragiles qui pourraient trinquer les
plus modestes et la bonne nouvelle c'est
que il n'y aura pas de baisse de pension
pas de baisse des retraites et que les
jeunes n'auront pas à payer de retraite
la note si j'ose dire et puis et puis la
leur pas plus non plus de notamment
d'augmentation d'impôts le Sénat qui
adopte ses conclusions parce que c'est
ce qu'on a entendu dans les prises de
parole notamment de René Paul Savary le
texte final le la CMP était globalement
le texte de la droite et du centre du
Sénat c'est bien ça je pense que depuis
le départ on a imprimé une marque très
très forte au Sénat puisque tous les ans
nous votion cette amendement et
l'architecture de la réforme c'est à
dire 43 annuités et accélération voilà
64 ans viennent ici mais surtout on a
enrichi l'hôtel on l'a
ne comprend pas d'un point de vue
politique qu'est-ce qui fait l'honneur
de la politique c'est la constance c'est
une ligne politique comment comprendre
que alors que depuis des années et des
mois encore ont soutenait une réforme
qui portait à 65 ans
politique pour votre parti politique
c'est un sérieux avertissement et pardon
mais ça conforte ce que je dis depuis
des années je crois que avant de penser
au présidentiel de grâce pensons à
redéfinir ce que nous sommes ce que nous
voulons notre lit laïque on va proposer
aux Français parce que sinon on ne sera
pas lisible et donc on sera pas audible
générale la question est-ce que vous le
dites à l'exécutif allez-y déclencher
49-3 et il n'y a pas les troupes chez
les LR pour voter la réforme à
l'Assemblée nationale vous qui êtes à
l'intérieur du parti non je l'ai dit
d'ailleurs dans votre matinale ce matin
je pense que il vaut mieux quand même un
vote que pas de vote du tout que le 49-3
mais mais il vaut quand même mieux un
49-3 si jamais il y a pas de majorité
plutôt que le rejet de cette réforme qui
est une réforme indispensable et plus on
perdra du temps
et plus ensuite ça sera douloureux pour
sauver les retraites par répartition
[Musique]